damn bruh
i don't know why i just wish it was like
the old school music still i'll just be
wanting to make it like a beanie siegel
uh like what do you [ __ ] know about i
want to make like a remake of his whole
album like
which album i forgot what the name
you've listened to
it was like it was like a little prison
looking [ __ ] it was like the truth
there's the truth the reason the
becoming you know yeah that [ __ ] is
hard i was listening to that [ __ ] last
night too i had no idea you listen but
yeah you even listen to that i want to
remake every [ __ ] song
in here why don't you do a song with
being this evil i mean you still make me
still
of course i mean you're not qualified
[ __ ] tap in man i'm not qualified to
make it no no no no no
you don't remember when he said that on
on the breakfast club charlotte i'm like
damn [ __ ] i ain't even know cuz still
made music though i ain't gonna lie
i thought it was just even if he didn't
make property
yo yeah no i think they're working on
some like uh i i always see him in
freeway
and young chris i mean young chris is
still active
but you don't know about that bro yeah i
know young chris but i know uh
the young guns bro the young guns what
the [ __ ] was they in
state property bro i probably chris and
me i probably know how they look
jay-z legitimately like may or may not
have kind of
already been jacked down chris's flow
yeah
yeah i know that's that's the young guy
yeah i never knew that yeah
well i don't know now you know bro now i
know uh
you must be from out there or something
philly no i'm from [ __ ] arizona
brother
from [ __ ] here bro [ __ ] this guy oh
mother mirror i don't know bro
don't buy his album [ __ ] this [ __ ] man
don't take me home man don't deal with
this
don't stream his [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] yo
we was calling females [ __ ] earlier
let's cancel them wow
let's just cancel them you know
sometimes it's good it's good we was
calling the hoes [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
hoes earlier
down with the [ __ ] in the house bill
gleckman hey
i heard this the uh joe rogan said this
sometimes you got a little [ __ ] joe
rogan
do you not know who joe rogan is joe
rogan joe rogan
fear factor fear factor fear factor you
got the biggest [ __ ] podcast in the
world
fear factor what is fear factor again
don't worry about it man all right yeah
you're [ __ ]